>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Dieses Jahr ist ja ein bisschen ein besonderes Jahr.
Und ich erinnere mich noch ganz gut
an den Anfang des Jahres.
Wir hatten unser Flipchart, haben uns alle hingesetzt,
haben die ganzen Projekte und Messen
für dieses Jahr durchgesprochen
und ich dachte mir noch Anfang des Jahres:
"O mein Gott! Wie will ich diese ganzen Messen schaffen?"
Dennoch freue ich mich jedes Jahr wirklich
immer auf den September,
auf die erste Septemberwoche,
auf das erste Septemberwochenende.
Denn da findet immer die IFA in Berlin statt,
also die größte internationale Technikmesse.
Und da bin ich ja schon seit über vier Jahren
mit Bosch gemeinsam
und stelle euch dort die neuesten technischen Highlights vor.
Und die Messe ist für mich wirklich so ein absolutes Muss.
Und ich weiß noch ganz genau,
als meine Freundin heiraten wollte
und sie wollte ihre Hochzeit auf das Wochenende legen,
habe ich schon gesagt: "Lisa, nein.
Geht nicht. Ich kann nicht zu deiner Hochzeit kommen.
Denn ich gehe zu Bosch auf die IFA."
Und dann hat sie ihre Hochzeit sogar noch umgelegt.
Das weiß ich noch.
Und dieses Jahr...
Also ich hätte es echt nie erwartet,
wahrscheinlich keiner von uns.
Und als dann die Corona-Pandemie ausgebrochen ist,
war natürlich ganz schnell klar, dass die IFA nicht stattfindet.
Und das war für mich tatsächlich, muss ich echt sagen
– ich war schon sehr enttäuscht.
Klar, du kannst nicht auf eine Messe gehen,
wenn gerade total die Pandemie ist.
Und das war einfach so:
"Oh, wow! Unser Berlin-Wochenende findet nicht statt.
Wir gehen nicht auf die Messe."
Und für mich war es einfach
die letzten Jahre immer richtig toll,
weil ich dort in der Küche mich austoben konnte.
Ich habe gekocht und gebacken und
Hunderte und Tausende von euch waren zu Gast da.
Wir haben uns unterhalten und kennengelernt,
Autogrammstunden gemacht.
Es ging natürlich auch um die Highlights,
um die neuen Innovationen.
Und ich habe da wirklich immer
superintensive Tage verbracht.
Und ja,
das war halt dieses Jahr schon so wie so ein Luftballon,
der einfach so – blubb – zerplatzt.
Und wir haben uns echt gefragt:
"Na toll. Was machen wir dieses Jahr?"
Und natürlich hat Bosch dieses Jahr
auch wieder ganz, ganz viele Highlights
und viele Innovationen entwickelt.
Und die wollten wir auch vorstellen.
Und wir haben uns wirklich gemeinsam mit Bosch hingesetzt
und haben überlegt: "Ja, was machen wir denn jetzt?"
Und für mich war es dann echt
– allein schon, dass sie mich gefragt haben.
Also Bosch ist für mich nicht einfach so eine Firma,
die da so existiert.
Das sind wirklich langjährige Partner,
aber noch viel mehr langjährige Freunde.
Und eins muss ich noch sagen:
Mit Bosch arbeite ich schon wirklich
seit über vier Jahren zusammen.
Und es ist nicht einfach eine Partnerschaft,
sondern es ist wirklich eine Freundschaft entstanden.
Und ich habe mich damals auch für Bosch entschieden,
weil ich die Menschen, die dort arbeiten,
einfach so sehr geschätzt habe.
Und es war einfach sofort
– so der Sympathiefaktor ist übergesprungen.
Also, wenn ich da jetzt an Harald denke, an Tinus, an Toni,
an Florence, an den Michael,
dann muss ich halt echt sagen,
dass mir da auch schon die Freundschaft
wichtiger ist sogar als die Partnerschaft.
Und es hat einfach von Anfang an super gepasst.
Und gerade, wenn ich an die Bosch-Geräte denke,
die sind so bodenständig.
Man hat wirklich was von wenig Technik bis viel Technik.
Jemand wie meine Mutter zum Beispiel,
die dann sagt: "Oh, nicht zu viel Technik",
nimmt sich dann ein bisschen was Einfacheres.
Jemand, der sagt:
"Ich möchte mir den Arbeitsalltag erleichtern",
der kann natürlich auch zu künstlicher Intelligenz zurückgreifen
und sich wirklich beim Kochen und Backen leiten lassen.
Aber, wie gesagt, das ist einfach eine Freundschaft,
die jetzt auch über die Jahre entstanden ist.
Und für mich war es echt ein krasser Ritterschlag,
dass ich jetzt diese IFA-Messe
einfach bei mir zu Hause habe stattfinden lassen dürfen.
Also vielleicht an der Stelle
noch mal vielen, vielen Dank an euch!
Tinus und Toni und Harald,
danke für euer Vertrauen!
Und danke, dass ich das Ganze
bei mir zu Hause machen durfte.
Wie ihr euch vielleicht vorstellen könnt,
das Ganze wurde jetzt nicht lange im Voraus geplant.
Denn die Pandemie hat uns alle plötzlich getroffen.
Plötzlich kam der Lockdown.
Plötzlich war überall alles geschlossen.
Und wir haben jetzt überlegt:
"Okay. Wie machen wir es? Wo und
vor allem wann?"
Und es war wirklich so eine krasse Kurzschlussreaktion.
Sie haben mir die ganzen neuen Geräte gezeigt.
Wir haben
– innerhalb von zwei Wochen
wurden die Drehbücher geschrieben.
Denn ihr müsst euch vorstellen:
Wenn ich auf der Messe bin,
dann habe ich da die Annette neben mir von Bosch.
Die erklärt mir dann alles, was neu ist,
was die neuen Features sind, die neuen Funktionen sind.
Und dann erklärt sie mir das.
Ich stehe dann vor dem Gerät
und erkläre es euch in die Kamera.
Jetzt natürlich musste alles gut vorbereitet werden.
Und wir haben uns dann auch dazu bereit erklärt,
unser komplettes Haus sozusagen freizugeben
und zu sagen: "Okay, baut einfach alles ein,
wo ihr wollt und wie ihr es wollt."
Ich habe das Ganze ein bisschen unterschätzt,
muss ich sagen.
Weil wir saßen da sonntags noch auf der Terrasse
und ich wusste: "Okay, das Drehteam rückt jetzt an."
Und dann kamen da plötzlich Lkws an
und Menschen
und haben einfach so
komplett das ganze Haus irgendwie umgebaut.
Aber dazu später noch.
Ja. Und wir wollten das Ganze, muss ich auch sagen,
am Anfang selber drehen,
also Josh und Vivi
und der Frank und Marcel und alle.
Aber das Ganze war einfach zeitlich nicht möglich,
weil wir wirklich zeitlich auch sehr eingespannt waren.
Und wir hatten
– wir persönlich oder ich persönlich –
einfach nur diese eine Woche Zeit,
die ganzen Videos zu drehen.
Und deswegen haben wir es zeitlich nicht hingekriegt.
Also hatten wir ein richtig cooles
Produktionsteam an der Seite.
Und die haben sich dann auch zusammengesetzt
mit Tinus und Florence und Bosch
und haben dann gesagt:
"Okay. Wir schreiben jetzt die Drehbücher."
Wir haben
– ich glaube, es waren 14 Geräte insgesamt
oder sogar mehr.
Aber wir haben 14 Videos eben am Ende gemacht.
Und wir haben dann Drehbücher geschrieben.
Weil da war es wirklich so,
wir mussten praktisch von Sequenz zu Sequenz
– es wurde immer so ein Teil des Hauses beleuchtet.
Und da ist es dann nicht so,
dass man dann eine Lampe hinstellt,
sondern es war wirklich ein komplettes Set-up
wie bei einem Werbedreh eben auch.
Und so was muss man natürlich gut vorbereiten.
Also wurden Drehbücher geschrieben,
was ich alles sagen möchte,
was ich alles vorstellen möchte.
Und für mich war die Schwierigkeit darin,
dass ich praktisch nicht einen Film
von Anfang bis Ende fertig drehen konnte,
sozusagen über einen Geschirrspüler zum Beispiel.
Weil so was kann ich, muss ich schon sagen,
aus dem Stegreif.
Also ich kann mich da hinstellen
und über die Geschirrspülmaschine erzählen,
was sie an Neuheiten hat,
Funktionen, Reinigung, Bedienung.
Aber, wenn du natürlich 24 Geräte im Kopf haben musst
und dann immer wieder verschiedene Set-ups hast
und verschiedene Drehorte,
muss das natürlich alles niedergeschrieben werden.
Und so haben wir das gemacht.
Und so wurde einmal unser komplettes Haus belagert
und wir haben angefangen, die Videos zu drehen.
Und das war alles
megakrass!
Murat hat das Ganze backstage ein bisschen begleitet.
Und ich glaube, Murat hat euch auch
ein bisschen was dazu zu erzählen.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Ja. Also das ist ein unglaublich krasses Team,
was hier ist.
Also in der Größenordnung haben wir noch nie gefilmt.
Wir haben schon mal in der Größenordnung gedreht.
Für VOX war das mal,
wo wir die Sally-Serie gemacht haben.
Und jetzt haben sie unsere komplette Garage
in Beschlag genommen.
Guck mal. So sieht momentan meine Garage aus.
Alles vollgestellt
mit Produkten, die eingebaut werden,
oder Sets, wenn sie gewechselt werden.
Es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn.
Und es wird jetzt zehn Tage lang so sein.
Das heißt, zehn Tage lang
wird unser Haus komplett in Beschlag genommen
für diesen Dreh, für diesen virtuellen Rundgang
von der IFA.
Und die IFA ist in Waghäusel angekommen.
Also man hat ja zu uns immer gesagt:
"Sally, eigentlich müsstest du nach Berlin.
Da ist alles. Da kannst du noch größer werden."
Und wir haben gesagt: "Nee, wir bleiben hier."
Und jetzt ist Berlin, ist die IFA
und jetzt ist die IFA hier in Waghäusel.
Eine richtig gigantische Geschichte!
Jetzt fliegen auch schon die Hubschrauber.
Die suchen wahrscheinlich den Güni.
Und das ist das ganze Set.
So. Und die wollen den Güni.
Die suchen Güni.
>> PILOT: Nine-thirty-one-five may not contact One-five.
One-one-eight-point-one-five,
if you do not establish communications
come back to us immediatly on...
>> MURAT: Momentan macht das Wetter mit.
Und hier sitzt das ganze Team, isst nachher.
Wir haben einen Caterer.
Und zwar das Coole ist auch noch
– ihr wisst ja, dank Corona
geht es den ganzen Caterern
und den ganzen Restaurants hier natürlich nicht so gut.
Und, da jetzt so viele Menschen da sind,
haben die Leute auch was von unserer Region davon.
Und das ist das
Cristall, Hotel Cristall in Kirrlach,
das uns hier beliefert mit Essen,
mit Getränken und mit allem Drum und Dran.
Und hier hinten seht ihr schon ein bisschen
den Lkw mit der Ware drin.
Hier, gerade hier vorne seht ihr noch einen Lkw mit Ware drin.
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn!
Das ist eine richtige Materialschlacht, was hier gemacht wird.
Es ist wie ein riesiger Kinofilmdreh
bei uns in Waghäusel.
Und jetzt gehen wir mal noch in die anderen Räume.
Dass ihr mir das glaubt, was hier alles gerade passiert,
gehen wir jetzt mal kurz rein.
Und da ist nämlich die Sally gerade am Drehen
und es geht gerade um den Backofen.
Ich glaube, es geht um die Serie 8,
um die Carbon Black Edition, die wir selber haben.
Da gibt es ein paar coole Neuheiten.
Künstliche Intelligenz!
Also wirklich künstliche Intelligenz.
Das ist was ganz Cooles.
Künstliche Intelligenz heißt,
der Backofen lernt mit.
Das heißt, jetzt wird natürlich Güni ein Problem haben.
Wenn der Backofen schon schlauer ist als er,
hat der Güni natürlich ein Problem.
Ist leider so.
Und das Video zu dem Backofen mit künstlicher Intelligenz,
das seht ihr mal jetzt, was die Sally gedreht hat.
So sieht es nämlich aus.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Die neuen Backöfen mit KI,
also künstlicher Intelligenz,
erleichtern mir den Alltag enorm.
Sie lernen durch eine stetig wachsende Anzahl
an Informationen aus zahlreichen Back- und Bratvorgängen
der Home Connect Community ständig dazu.
Je öfter und intensiver ein KI-Backofen genutzt wird,
desto genauer kann er vorhersagen,
wann der Kuchen oder Braten fertig ist.
>> MURAT: Dieser Lkw hier zum Beispiel
ist voll mit Lichtequipment.
Licht ist saumäßig wichtig bei so einem Dreh.
Und, wie gesagt, der ganze Lkw ist voll mit Lichtern,
Folien und Ständern und was weiß ich was.
Eine unglaubliche Summe!
Ich bin mir ganz, ganz sicher
– Josh, was meinst du,
was der ganze Lkw-Inhalt kostet?
Eine halbe Million wird reichen?
>> JOSH: Ja, ungefähr. Vielleicht auch mehr.
>> MURAT: Also mehr?
Ungefähr mehr als eine halbe Million ist wirklich der Wahnsinn!
Nur mit Lichttechnik.
Meistens ist es so, dass sich solche Unternehmen
das nicht selber kaufen,
sondern immer Filmverleihe das immer ausleihen.
Gibt es fast in jeder größeren Stadt,
so riesengroße Filmverleihe.
Und, wie gesagt, alles eingepackt mit allem Drum und Dran.
Eine ganz gigantische Geschichte!
So. Bei uns daheim gibt es eine goldene Regel.
Egal, ob der Präsident kommt oder die Königin
oder der Kaiser,
wer auch immer,
bei uns heißt die goldene Regel:
Zu Hause immer Schuhe ausziehen.
Daran muss sich jeder halten.
Ich muss auch immer wiederum sagen:
"Leute, zieht eure Schuhe aus."
Bei mir daheim läuft keiner rum ohne Schuhe
oder diese Slippies.
Und diese Slippies, die zieht man sich einfach
über die Schuhe drüber.
Zack!
So.
Man nimmt den Schmutz nicht mit nach Hause.
Warum ich das selber gerade mache,
warum ich in keinen Socken rumlaufe?
Ich finde immer, ohne Schuhe
sehe ich ziemlich klein aus.
Und deswegen ziehe ich die Dinger jetzt an
vor der Kamera.
So.
Zack!
Die kann man auch wiederverwenden.
Jetzt gehen wir rein.
[Musik]
So. Im Real Life
ist das normalerweise der Raum von der Sarah,
von unserer Fotografin.
Und jetzt sitzt die Anna da.
Und die Anna, die ist auch von der Filmcrew
und sie ist Kameratechnikerin.
Richtig, Anna?
>> ANNA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und was sie jetzt gerade macht?
Und zwar: Sie tut gerne Daten wrangeln,
nennt sich das.
Das heißt, sie speichert die ganzen Daten auf Karten,
auf Sticks und allem Drum und Dran.
Und man sieht hier schon ein bisschen die ganzen Videos.
Das ist gerade das Video, wo die Sally
den Backofen mit der künstlichen Intelligenz erklärt, richtig?
>> ANNA: Ja.
>> MURAT: Genau, künstliche Intelligenz.
Das ist, wenn der Backofen schlauer ist als der Ehemann,
richtig?
>> ANNA: So ungefähr.
>> MURAT: Ja. Siehst du?
Genau, absolut richtig.
Auf jeden Fall eine coole Geschichte.
Und sie speichert die ganzen Daten.
Da darf nichts verloren gehen.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt einen ganzen Drehtag gemacht
– und ein Drehtag kostet richtig, richtig Asche.
Richtig? Habe ich recht?
>> ANNA: Jawoll.
>> MURAT: Genau. Und plötzlich sind die Daten weg.
Dann hat man ein Riesenproblem.
>> ANNA: Danke. Mach mir Druck.
>> MURAT: Ja, echt?
Ist es dir schon mal passiert? Sei mal ehrlich.
>> ANNA: Nein.
>> MURAT: Noch nie passiert?
>> ANNA: Gott sei Dank.
>> MURAT: Weil du eine schlaue Anna bist. Genau.
>> ANNA: Gott sei Dank nicht. Nein.
>> MURAT: Ja. Anna ist eine schlaue Anna.
Ihr ist es noch nie passiert.
Uns ist es schon mal passiert, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Wir haben wirklich mal zwei Drehtage gehabt
und dann waren die Karten einfach kaputt.
Ja.
>> ANNA: Ja, das kann passieren.
Deswegen machen wir auch immer ein Back-up.
Das heißt, ich mache von jeder Festplatte
noch mal ein Back-up.
>> MURAT: Eine Kopie? Okay.
Hier in diesem Raum normalerweise
tut die Sarah Fotos bearbeiten.
Und jetzt hockt die Anna drin
und tut dann sieben Tage jetzt Daten wrangeln.
Genau. Danke, Anna.
>> ANNA: Gerne, gerne.
>> MURAT: So.
Jetzt gehen wir weiter und zwar:
Jetzt gehen wir eigentlich in das richtige Fotostudio von uns,
wo eigentlich die Sarah und unsere Fotografen
die ganzen Fotos machen.
Und wie es dadrin aussieht,
das glaubt ihr mir nicht.
Weil ich habe da ein Vorher- und ein Nachherbild.
Und ich zeige euch erst mal das Nachherbild.
So. Das ist normalerweise der Raum,
wo wir eigentlich Fotos schießen auf unserem Holzbrett.
Und der ist auch wieder vollgestellt, voll mit Technik.
Und nur mal ein bisschen,
dass ihr ein bisschen was von der Technik versteht,
um wie viel Geld es hier eigentlich geht
– wie gesagt, es ist geliehen.
Es ist auch nicht von mir geliehen.
Und zwar allein diese Objektive hier,
also dieser Tisch locker mal um die 200 Granaten
mindestens.
Mindestens!
Dann, was wir hier auch haben,
ist eine ALEXA Mini
und zwar gerade die mit dem Prompter.
Die ist zwar fünf Jahre ungefähr alt.
Hier bist du auch schon noch mal locker dabei
mit 100.000 €.
Also das Ding ist wirklich,
hier in diesem Raum steht locker jetzt ungelogen mal
eine Dreiviertelmillion bis Million nur an Equipment.
>> SALLY: Und wenn ich drin stehe?
>> MURAT: Ja. Dann, wenn die Sally drin steht,
steht schon mal eine Million mehr drin.
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung?!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Aber, wenn so ein Fußballspieler schon 20 kriegt
>> SALLY: und wert ist?
>> MURAT: Dann ist die Sally mindestens zwei Millionen wert.
Mindestens!
Ich bin unbezahlbar.
Nicht mal mit der Mastercard kann man mich bezahlen.
Also ein richtig krasse Geschichte,
eine Materialschlacht, eine Technikschlacht.
Aber da seht ihr mal,
wie cool oder wie wichtig und wie viel Arbeit
so ein ganz kleiner Werbespot eigentlich ist.
Und ja,
gerade, wenn wir gerade bei Werbespots sind,
gehen wir dann zum nächsten Werbespot.
Und zwar geht es hier um die
– sagt man da Entlüftungsanlage oder Belüftungsanlage?
>> SALLY: Wozu?
>> MURAT: Die Scheibe, wo so hochfährt.
>> SALLY: Nein, Dunstabzug!
>> MURAT: Ah, Dunstabzugshaube.
Und zwar gibt es da was ganz, ganz Krasses.
>> SALLY: Das ist der Kochdunst.
>> MURAT: Ja, der Kochdunst
wird abgezogen mit einer krassen Scheibe momentan.
Ist der neueste Hit
von Bosch.
Gibt es jetzt auch demnächst beim Handel.
Und die Sally hat dieses Video gedreht.
Was da für eine coole Kameratechnik dahintersteckt
und wie cool dieser Spot eigentlich geworden ist,
das sehr ihr mal jetzt.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Mein absolutes Highlight
unter den aktuellen Bosch-Neuheiten
ist dieser Dunstabzug,
der sich wie kein anderer perfekt in meine Küche einfügt.
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt sind wir bei uns in der Küche
oder was es mal vorher war.
Und ihr seht, das ist eine richtig krasse Geschichte,
wie viel da Technik dahintersteckt.
Komm mal kurz mit.
Der Roman ist gerade dabei.
Und zwar filmt er den Backofen gerade.
Und hier ist ein richtiges Labyrinth aufgebaut.
Und guck mal, hier geht es weiter.
Also ihr seht, es ist ein ganz anderes Filmen.
Also das sieht nicht aus wie meine Küche zu Hause.
Und jetzt müssen wir auch ein bisschen still sein.
Und still sein ist eigentlich das nächste Schlagwort.
Weil da gibt es auch was richtig Cooles.
Da hat Sally ein Video gerade eben gemacht.
Und zwar geht es um eine Spülmaschine,
die so leise ist, dass man eigentlich
eine Stecknadel fallen hört.
Und dieses Video dazu,
das schaut euch mal jetzt an.
Jungs, wenn ihr Hilfe braucht, ihr wisst Bescheid.
Ich hatte den größten Dönerladen in Karlsruhe.
Ja.
So. Die lachen alle.
Man sieht es nicht wegen den Masken.
Aber ich höre es.
>> SALLY: Mehr Leistung, weniger Verbrauch,
das zeichnet die neuen PerfectDry Geschirrspüler aus.
Die neue Geschirrspülerreihe hat es wirklich in sich.
Mit einer Topaustattung,
unglaublich sparsam,
100 Prozent vernetzt,
leise
und auf Knopfdruck noch leiser.
>> MURAT: Das war mal früher der Raum,
wo wir gegessen haben mit dem ganzen Team zusammen.
Alles komplett abgedunkelt, alles dunkel gemacht.
Hier wird wirklich
– das Licht ist so extrem wichtig bei einem Dreh.
Ich glaube, wir haben allein nur das Licht
einen ganzen Tag aufgestellt,
einen ganzen Tag Licht aufgestellt
und draußen ein Sonnensegel gemacht
bei uns im Garten.
Da gehen wir jetzt auch mal kurz hin.
Es ist wirklich wich-
– Licht ist eines der wichtigsten Dinge beim Videodreh.
Gehen wir kurz raus? Ich zeige es euch mal ganz kurz.
[Musik]
Die drei,
das sind die drei von der Tankstelle.
Und zwar: Die sind für die Technik zuständig, die Jungs.
Das heißt, die bauen die ganzen Küchen zusammen,
auseinander und alles Drum und Dran.
Oder? Stimmt's?
Du bist auch dabei, gell?
Hier?
Kommt mal kurz mit. Ich zeige es euch kurz.
So sieht momentan unser Kräutergarten aus.
Und da war mal die Terrasse.
Und da ist jetzt alles abgedunkelt,
dass einfach
– einfach wegen dem Lichteinfall.
Saumäßig!
Also wirklich einen ganzen Tag nur für das Licht.
Ja.
So, Jungs, dann gehen wir mal was essen gleich, oder?
Habt ihr auch Hunger?
>> MONTEUR: Wenn du was isst,
müssen wir die Spülmaschine tauschen.
>> MURAT: Also, wenn ich was esse,
müsst ihr erst die Spülmaschine tauschen?
Die dadrin in unserem Ding?
>> MONTEUR: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay.
Also, wie gesagt, nach jedem Dreh
wird immer etwas getauscht.
Und jetzt gleich die Spülmaschine.
[Musik]
Und das sind wirklich ganz, ganz
– immer ganz, ganz schnelle Wechsel.
Das heißt, Maschine rein, Maschine raus,
ein neues Gerät rein, ein neues Gerät raus.
Es muss ein fliegender Wechsel sein.
Es geht hier wirklich um Zeit, weil es ist wirklich so,
dass jeder Drehtag unglaublich viel Geld kostet,
unglaublich viel Arbeit ist.
Und deswegen müssen wir so schnell fertig werden,
wie es nur geht.
Und wir machen das schon, Jungs. Gell, ihr kriegt das hin?
Macht das einfach so,
wie ich es euch schon einmal gezeigt habe.
Die Rohre nicht vertauschen.
Und dann läuft das Ding.
Es hört keiner auf mich.
>> MONTEUR: So und Umluft an Umluft.
>> MURAT: Genau, Umluft an Umluft.
Genau, das ist wichtig.
So.
Und, wie gesagt, unsere Küche komplett umgestellt.
So sieht es hier auch aus.
Also richtig dunkel.
Könnt ihr mich noch sehen, Josh? Ist es noch hell genug?
>> JOSH: Ja, gerade so.
>> MURAT: Echt? Gerade noch so?
Okay.
Ja.
[Musik]
Was ich aber ganz cool finde, sind
Home-Connect-fähige Backöfen.
Das bringt wirklich was.
Weil ihr wisst ja zum Beispiel,
dass es die Sally App gibt.
Und zwar gibt es die Sally App,
wo sie ihre ganzen Rezepte drauf hat.
Die kannst du an den Backofen schicken
und der Backofen stellt automatisch die Heizart ein,
also 4D Heißluft, Umluft,
Unter-/Oberhitze, Umluft, wie auch immer,
stellt es automatisch ein und auch die Zeit.
Das heißt, ihr müsst nichts mehr machen
als einfach mit dem Handy das an den Backofen schicken.
Und da gibt es auch richtig coole Assist-Funktionen.
Das heißt, du hast ein schönes Rinderfilet,
– wenn du jetzt nicht Veganer bist –
tust das Rinderfilet in den Backofen,
machst die Assist-Funktion und sagst einfach:
"Rinderfilet, 800 Gramm" zum Beispiel,
je nachdem, wie viel Kilo du drin hast.
Und dann kommt das Filet wirklich perfekt raus.
Du musst nicht mehr nachschauen.
Da sind die Sensoren, die im Backofen drin sind.
Ganz gigantische Geräte!
Die Serie 8, Home-Connect-fähige Geräte,
wird durch die Decke gehen,
weil sie einfach sinnhaft sind.
Und das Video hatte meine Frau gestern schon gedreht.
Sie kann es besser erklären als ich.
Ansonsten wäre ich das Gesicht von Bosch.
Leider bin ich nicht das Gesicht von Bosch.
Das ist meine Frau.
Und die erklärt euch das in dem folgenden Werbespot,
wie das funktioniert.
>> SALLY: Mit Home Connect kann ich meine Kreativität
in der Küche voll und ganz ausleben.
Ich kann einfach in der großen Rezeptsammlung stöbern
und die unterschiedlichsten Gerichte ausprobieren.
Die Einstellungen aus dem Rezept schicke ich dann
direkt aus der Home Connect App
an meinen Backofen.
[Musik]
Ich meine: Wie soll ich in meinem Garten Minze holen,
wenn ich nicht in meinen Garten komme?
Josh, ich mache jetzt was.
Wenn was passiert, war es ein Arbeitsunfall, okay?
>> JOSH: Hm. Okay.
>> SALLY: Aber kein fahrlässiger, okay?
>> JOSH: Nee, das war vollkommen gerechtfertigt.
>> SALLY: Okay?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Da-da-da!
[Musik]
Hat sich gelohnt!
Ah, schön!
Guck.
Ja,
die Minze, die macht es.
War ein guter Einsatz.
>> MURAT: So. Und zwar das ist jetzt
so ein neuer Kühlschrank.
Der hat wahnsinnige Sachen.
Das soll euch meine Frau erklären.
Und was halt auch cool ist
– er ist natürlich schwarz. Klar.
Aber das ist jetzt nicht die Neuheit.
Das Coole ist, der hat eine No-Fingerprint-Oberfläche.
Das heißt, du kannst wirklich alles machen,
wenn du Kinder hast, drübergehen.
Es gibt keine Flecken.
>> SALLY: Mit den neuen geräumigen und komfortablen
Side-by-Side-Kühl-/Gefrierkombinationen
bietet Bosch jetzt eine große Auswahl
in unterschiedlichen Preisklassen an.
Mein Favorit bei den Neuzugängen
ist dieses Schätzchen hier.
Sowohl die Front als auch die Seitenwände
sind in stylischem Schwarz gestaltet.
>> MURAT: Guck.
Hier.
Du bist auch null aufgeregt, gell?
Ich finde das auch der Hammer!
Die macht wirklich
– hier haut sie mal kurz 22 Erklärvideos raus
aus den ganzen Backöfen,
was es alles gibt,
Scheibenwischer,
Waschmaschinen
und was weiß ich was.
Du bist null aufgeregt, gell?
>> SALLY: Nee, weil ich kenne es ja.
>> MURAT: Ah! Und ich sehe gerade,
du hast ein bisschen Gemüse zwischen den Zähnen.
O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Ich muss in die Maske.
>> MURAT: Lass mal gucken.
Mach mal so.
Immer noch.
>> SALLY: Echt jetzt?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und das sagt mir kein Mensch?
>> MURAT: Ja, voll.
>> SALLY: Ich habe locker schon mit 20 Leuten hier geredet.
>> MURAT: Echt?
Es traut sich keiner was zu sagen. O mein Gott!
>> SALLY: Mann, ey!
>> MURAT: Ja, alle drei Tage drehen umsonst,
weil sie Gemüse zwischen den Zähnen hat.
Und keiner hat es ihr gesagt.
Kommt alles vor.
>> SALLY: Ich habe gar kein Gemüse zwischen den Zähnen!
>> MURAT: Natürlich hast du Gemüse zwischen den Zähnen.
>> SALLY: Das sagst du ja.
>> MURAT: Das ist ein ganzer Baum,
was du zwischen den Zähnen hast.
>> JULIA: Du siehst aus wie ein ganzer Baum
zwischen den Zähnen!
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]
So. Jetzt gehen wir mal einen geheimen Ort.
Und zwar: Das, was aussieht wie ein WC,
ist auch ein WC.
Ja.
Und zwar ist hier die Maske
für den ganzen Dreh.
Und die Maske macht die Julia.
So. Und die Julia ist unsere Freundin
und zwar schon seit zwei Jahren, gell?
Seit zwei Jahren wohnt sie hier
in dem Raum hier.
Wir klopfen dann immer.
Dann macht sie die Tür auf und sagt:
"Ja, hallo! Guten Morgen!"
Und dann laufen wir rein.
>> SALLY: Dann macht sie Miau.
>> JULIA: Miau!
>> MURAT: Genau.
Die Julia, die war schon bei uns,
als wir die Serie mit VOX gemacht haben.
Und zwar war das "Backen mit Sally"
– "Kochen mit Sally"?
War das?
"Singen mit Sally" war es nicht.
>> SALLY: "Einfach Sally".
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> MURAT: "Einfach Sally".
Und hier wird dann die Sally geschminkt.
Normalerweise mache ich das immer.
Aber heute geht es natürlich nicht.
Und ja,
es ist auch interessant vielleicht für andere Zuschauer.
Ihr kennt ja diese Beauty Tutorials.
Was tust du jetzt da gerade drauf?
Wie nennt sich das?
>> SALLY: Das weißt du doch als Make-up Artist, Murat.
>> MURAT: Nude.
So.
Sie macht Nude drauf,
nennt sich das.
Nennt sich das Nude?
>> JULIA: Nude Air.
>> MURAT: Ja, Nude Air.
>> SALLY: Das ist halt mein Make-up.
>> MURAT: Also Luft,
Luft teuer verpackt.
>> JULIA: Richtig, weil mehr braucht deine Frau nicht.
>> MURAT: Genau.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> MURAT: Oh!
Darf ich mich gerade kurz,
wenn ich schon an einer Kloschüssel bin,
mich kurz übergeben?
Aua!
Auf jeden Fall
>> JULIA: Eben sage ich es noch.
>> MURAT: also ganz cool.
Und jetzt wird sie geschminkt
auf dem Klo.
Wenn man natürlich nicht die Räumlichkeiten hat...
>> SALLY: Entschuldigung?! Das ist mein Thron.
>> MURAT: Ja, Thron.
Ja, es ist ihr Thron, genau,
nicht Klo.
Ach, da habe ich aber einen großen Thron.
Ja.
Und was machst du jetzt?
Werden hier die Augenränder weggemacht?
Oder...
>> SALLY: Ja. Die habe ich wegen dir.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> JULIA: Ja. Ärgere...
>> MURAT: Uh!
>> JULIA: Ärgere deine Frau mal ein bisschen weniger.
Dann brauchen wir nicht so viel davon.
>> MURAT: Aber ich finde immer, umso älter sie wird,
umso schöner wird sie.
>> JULIA: Ja, die Frau ist wie ein Wein.
Die wird immer nur besser.
>> MURAT: Ah, das ist ein Mann.
Das ist normalerweise ein Männerspruch, gell?
>> JULIA: Auf gar keinen Fall.
>> MURAT: Das geht gar nicht.
So.
Wusstet ihr, dass der Mensch
– ab 25 stirbt der Mensch eigentlich.
Bis zu 25, also ab 24,
wächst alles beim Mensch
und dann beginnt der innerliche Verfall.
Eigentlich beginnt ja schon das Sterben
ja eigentlich schon mit der Geburt.
Auch lustig, gell?
Das Krasse ist, das Sterben beginnt mit der Geburt,
mit 24 hört aber alles auf zu wachsen
bis auf die Hände,
auf die Füße, die Nase und die Ohren.
>> SALLY: Bei ihm beginnt das Verderben,
>> MURAT: Ja, bei mir wächst dann aber
– bei mir ist der Bauch weiter gewachsen.
Ich weiß nicht, was da falsch gelaufen ist.
>> SALLY: sobald er spricht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ja. Auf jeden Fall, jetzt geht es weiter.
Machst du da noch so ein Contouring noch?
Macht man so was?
So Contouring?
>> JULIA: Hat sie doch schon.
>> MURAT: Machst du das?
>> SALLY: Ich habe doch schon meine Konturen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Okay. Und was wird dann noch gemacht?
Wird dann noch so ein Bleaching gemacht?
Nennt sich das Bleaching?
>> JULIA: Nein.
>> SALLY: Ich hatte aber wirklich was zwischen den Zähnen.
>> MURAT: Echt? Ja?
Siehst du?
Und werden die Augenbrauen noch gezupft
oder bleibt das so?
>> JULIA: Willst du boxen oder soll ich?
>> MURAT: Weiß ich nicht.
Nein, es sieht ja schön aus alles.
>> SALLY: Ich mag sie buschig.
>> MURAT: Du, ja, magst so buschig.
Hast du das gerade gesagt?
Hör auf.
So.
>> SALLY: Meine Augenbrauen.
>> MURAT: Auf jeden Fall...
Ja.
>> SALLY: Wir müssen uns beeilen.
>> MURAT: Und wie kriegt man...
>> SALLY: Zwei Minuten haben wir nur noch. Zwei Minuten.
>> MURAT: Und wie kriegt man nachher die Farbe
alles wieder runter?
Gallseife?
>> JULIA: Einfach waschen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> JULIA: Oder hinten auf den Kopf hauen.
Dann fällt das runter.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Kärchern.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Ah, wir können mal durchkärchern.
Jawoll, wir kärchern durch.
>> SALLY: Auf keinen Fall!
>> MURAT: SC 4 kann ich nur empfehlen.
SC 4 Dampfreiniger.
Ganz toll.
>> SALLY: So einen Quatsch machen wir nicht.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und wie oft muss man das machen?
Vielleicht interessiert es euch ja.
Wie oft muss man das so schminken am Tag?
>> JULIA: Ach...
>> SALLY: Einmal morgens.
Und jetzt haben wir halt gegessen und so
und dann habe ich mir die Nase geputzt.
>> MURAT: Okay.
Gut.
Ich habe mich
– das letzte Mal, wo ich mich geschminkt habe,
war Hochzeit, 2008.
Was haben wir jetzt?
22, gell?
>> JULIA: Du warst geschminkt auf deiner Hochzeit?
>> MURAT: 20.
Habe ich 2008 geheiratet?
Stimmt, gell?
>> SALLY: Also ich ja. Du...
>> MURAT: Ja, krass. 2008 habe ich geheiratet.
Ja.
Wahnsinn!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Ja, da haben sie mich geschminkt
2008.
Und zwar
– soll ich mal die Bilder zeigen?
Komm, ich zeige mal ganz kurz ein Bild von 2008.
Und zwar hier.
Seht ihr das?
Sehe ich aus wie Ranjid, der Taxifahrer aus London?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja, gell? Wahnsinn!
>> MURAT: Okay.
Cool.
Du siehst gut aus!
Jetzt kannst du vor die Kamera.
Ah, was auch ganz wichtig ist:
Oftmals, wenn ihr das jetzt so seht
– nee, mit der Kamera seht ihr es jetzt nicht.
Wenn ich jetzt ein Foto schießen würde,
würdet ihr jetzt denken, sie ist überschminkt.
Aber die Kamera, die schluckt sehr, sehr viel.
Habe ich recht?
Julia, du hast Erfahrung.
>> JULIA: Ja, es ist eher das Licht,
was nachher auf sie drauf kommt.
>> MURAT: Aha.
>> JULIA: Die wird ja so dann beleuchtet,
dass sie halt total blass aussieht sonst.
>> MURAT: Ah, okay.
Also, wenn das Licht auf dich drauf kommt.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JULIA: Dann wird sie weggestrahlt quasi.
>> MURAT: Ich will keine komischen Gedanken im Kopf.
>> JULIA: Ich wollte gerade sagen,
die Pause war so lang, die kann nur schlimm sein.
>> MURAT: Ja, es war nur ein Gedanke.
Es war nur...
Das war einfach nur ein Gedankenstrich.
Das war einfach ein visueller Gedankenstrich.
Okay. Ich mache dann weiter.
Ich gehe jetzt mal rein und guck mal,
was die dadrin machen, okay?
>> JOSH: Können wir beide wieder drehen?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich bin bald wieder für dich da, Josh.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Dann übernehme ich dich wieder.
>> JOSH: Okay.
>> SALLY: Schatz, der Josh kann nicht mehr mit dir drehen.
Der hat was anderes zu tun.
>> JULIA: Der Josh kann nicht mit dir spielen.
>> MURAT: Josh, hör nicht auf die Frauen und komm mit!
Wir müssen Tischtennis spielen. Komm mit!
[Musik]
Das ist der Vario Kühlschrank von Bosch.
Den kennt ihr auch von der Messe vom letzten Jahr noch.
Der hat jetzt neue Styles, neue Farben.
Man kann sie individualisieren.
Und das Krasse ist,
wir haben jetzt natürlich hier nur einen einzigen
und in einer 3D-Animation wird der jetzt animiert.
Das heißt, du siehst
ganz, ganz, ganz viele verschiedene Designs,
ganz verschiedene Farben.
Und das ist ein ganzes Ding,
was nachher wirklich komplett 3D-animiert wird.
Hier steht er da
und so sieht es nachher im Video aus.
Und zwar genau so.
>> SALLY: Wer kennt das nicht?
Die richtige Farbe zu finden,
ist oftmals gar nicht so einfach.
Gefällt mir die Farbe, die ich heute auswähle,
auch noch morgen?
Die meisten Menschen entscheiden sich daher
oft für eine weiße Küche.
Aber das muss gar nicht sein.
>> MURAT: Lass die Kamera laufen, Josh.
Lass die Kamera laufen schnell.
>> SALLY: Du bist sonst nie so zärtlich.
>> MURAT: Okay. Komm, mach wieder aus.
Tschüss!
>> SALLY: Blödmann!
>> MURAT: Lass die Kamera laufen!
Lass die,
lass die Kamera laufen.
Oh, du bist so toll!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Au, mein Ohrstecker!
>> MURAT: Was sollen wir zu essen machen?
>> SALLY: Jetzt hast du mir dreimal
den Ohrstecker ins Ohr gerammt.
>> MURAT: Weißt du was? Ich mache
eine Spaghetti Bolognese, okay?
>> SALLY: Ach!
Kannst du nicht Tomatensugo machen
mit gegrillten Auberginen und Penne-Nudeln?
>> MURAT: Nee, das ist alles vegan.
Ich mache irgendwas mit Bolognese.
>> SALLY: Mhm.
Ich brauche Gemüse.
>> MURAT: Ja, wir machen Spaghetti mit Gemüse
und Bolognese.
>> SALLY: Tomatensugo.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Ja, wir macht man das?
>> SALLY: In der Sallys App,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Sallys Welt App
unter "Vegetarische Hauptspeisen".
>> MURAT: Ihr habt es gehört.
Ich mache jetzt Spaghetti Bolognese.
>> SALLY: Josh, bitte lass ihn nicht kochen.
>> JOSH: Okay.
Ich ziehe den Stecker vom Herd.
>> SALLY: Kannst du kochen?
>> JOSH: Ja, okay.
>> SALLY: Okay!
>> JOSH: Wir machen was Vegetarisches.
>> SALLY: Juhu!
[Musik]
Okay.
Ihr Lieben, heute ist Tag
fünf.
Und ich schlafe seit
vier Nächten nicht mehr.
Ja.
Weil meine Augen nachts immer flattern.
Und ich befürchte es ist
wegen den ganzen Bildschirmen und wegen
dem ganzen Licht.
Ich weiß nicht, Josh. Was machen wir so anders?
Und die ganzen Texte.
O mein Gott, die ganzen Texte!
Ja. Und nachts da
träume ich
– ich meine, das sind ja schöne Träume.
Weil ich träume dann so von PerfectBake,
PerfectRoast.
Aber es fliegen so die Buchstaben
vor meinem geistigen Auge an mir vorbei,
so weiß und schwarz.
Und dann so wuh!
>> JOSH: Nickst du ab und zu in der Maske ein?
>> SALLY: Ich nicke manchmal ein,
vor allem, wenn sie mit ihren Nägeln
so meine Kopfhaut krault.
Und dann schlafe ich so
und dann wache ich auf
– oh, das ist der Traum aller Frauen!
>> JULIA: Meinst du so?
>> SALLY: Ich schlafe ein, wache auf und sehe dann gut aus,
wenn sie mich dann geschminkt hat.
Woke up like this.
No filter, no makeup.
Ach, gell?
Ich merke heute echt, ich bin durch.
>> JULIA: So. Willkommen in den Fünfzigern.
Sie sind ready.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JULIA: Warte, warte.
>> SALLY: Ready to shoot.
Oh, ich würde so gern mal
so eine alte Waschtrocknerwerbung machen.
Weißt du? So von früher.
Wo ist mein Kopftuch?
In meinem Leben gibt es nur zwei Fragen,
die mich beschäftigen:
Was ziehe ich heute an?
Und was koche ich für meinen Mann?
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Ja, das ist das Set eigentlich
bei uns im Hauswirtschaftsraum.
Ja.
Und hier wird jetzt gleich gedreht,
wie die neuen Bosch-Waschmaschinen funktionieren.
Die sind richtig tricky.
Und zwar das Krasse ist, dass die Waschmaschinen
heutzutage schon intelligenter sind als der Güni.
Das ist auch mal schon
– ihr kennt doch die Geschichte, dass irgendwann mal
Cyborgs und Roboter die Menschheit übernehmen werden.
Weißt du, was ich meine?
Schlimm ist halt, wenn schon eine Waschmaschine
den Menschen übernimmt,
wie den Güni zum Beispiel.
>> SALLY: Also man muss schon dazu sagen,
dass die Waschmaschine
– die macht ja alles selbstständig, eigenständig
und macht die Wäsche nicht kaputt.
>> MURAT: Ja, alles, was er nicht kann.
>> SALLY: Ja, die macht die Wäsche nicht kaputt.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Das heißt, wenn ich vorher
von der i-DOS gehört hätte,
hätte ich gar nicht heiraten müssen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Aber du bist ja da.
>> MURAT: So.
Jetzt haben wir beide ein Problem
>> GÜNTER: Du musst weg.
>> MURAT: Wir werden beide nicht mehr gebraucht,
weil die Waschmaschine funktioniert.
>> GÜNTER: Nicht beide. Du!
>> MURAT: Aha!
Okay.
>> GÜNTER: Nicht auf mich mit.
>> MURAT: Aha.
So. Auf jeden Fall...
Und wie die funktioniert,
soll euch mal die Sally erklären, okay?
>> ANNA: 2-2-1, Take eins.
>> SALLY: Die neuen Waschtrockner von Bosch
sind wahre Alleskönner!
Waschen, Trocknen und Dampf in einem Gerät
für tragfertige Wäsche.
Waschtrockner sind die optimale Lösung in engen Räumen.
Die neuen Waschtrockner von Bosch
sind praktische Helfer für jeden,
nicht nur bei Platzproblemen.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So. Oben erklärt ja die Sally
die i-DOS Waschmaschine.
Und jetzt haben wir hier so ein Set
mit dem Güni zusammen aufgebaut die letzten zwei Tage.
Okay, der Josh hat geholfen.
Weißt du, was das Besondere an dieser Waschmaschine ist?
Hä?
>> GÜNTER: Die ist fast so groß wie du?
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt reicht es mir.
Vielleicht...
Mir fällt einfach nichts mehr ein.
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ich wollte gerade sagen:
Du, Güni, viel, viel cooler kommt,
wenn wir da hochklettern und dann uns draufsitzen
und dann die Moderation machen.
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
Komm, mach eine Räuberleiter.
>> MURAT: Klar, Spitzbubenleiter!
>> GÜNTER: Räuberleiter.
>> MURAT: Ah!
Aua!
So.
Okay.
Jetzt können wir die Anmoderation machen, Güni.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Guck mal, jetzt bist du
– du bist fast so groß wie ich.
>> MURAT: Ja!
So.
Auf jeden Fall das Coole an dieser Waschmaschine:
Das ist wie so ein altes Pärchen,
also eigentlich wie wir zwei.
Und diese zwei machen das, was wir zwei nicht machen.
Die kommunizieren miteinander.
Und zwar Folgendes:
Stell dir mal vor, in dieser Waschmaschine
tust du jetzt auf 60°C Baumwolle waschen, okay?
>> GÜNTER: Hm.
>> MURAT: Diese Waschmaschine
sagt dann zum Trockner:
"Hey, ich habe Baumwolle gewaschen auf 60°C."
Und die stellt sich automatisch ein.
Das heißt, du nimmst die Wäsche raus
und kannst sie einfach hier reinmachen
und musst nichts mehr einstellen.
Das ist alles automatisch.
Wahnsinn, oder?
Wieder so ein Produkt, wo man wieder merkt:
Schlauer als der Güni.
Können wir da eigentlich nicht so ein Logo
auf alle Bosch-Waschmaschinen draufschreiben:
"Schlauer als der Güni"?
Das wäre eine coole Geschichte.
>> GÜNTER: Moment mal.
>> MURAT: Nein! Nein! Nein! Bitte nicht!
Nicht! Bitte! Nein! Nein! Nein!
>> GÜNTER: Kurzer Cut.
>> MURAT: Nein! Nein! Aua! Aua!
Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Kurzer Cut.
>> MURAT: So. Auf jeden Fall...
Diese brutale Szene schneiden wir natürlich raus.
Und das andere Coole ist:
Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel
– wenn die Waschmaschine fertig ist,
– okay? –
dann kriegst du, wenn du möchtest,
eine Push-Benachrichtigung auf dein Handy,
wo es dann heißt:
"Güni, Waschmaschine ist fertig."
Du musst dann wirklich nur herlaufen,
das da reinmachen und das Ding läuft von alleine.
Wahnsinn, oder?
>> GÜNTER: Bei euch bist doch du
für die Wäsche zuständig, oder?
>> MURAT: Nein.
>> GÜNTER: "Schlauer als der Güni"?
>> MURAT: Ja, ich sage es doch.
>> GÜNTER: Du bist doch die Waschfrau!
>> MURAT: Also das ist, wie gesagt,
das alte Pärchen.
>> GÜNTER: Du bist doch die Waschfrau!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Das ist
– wenn daheim schon nicht mehr
mit dem Ehepartner kommuniziert wird,
machen es wenigstens die Waschmaschinen.
>> GÜNTER: Dann reden die Waschmaschinen.
>> MURAT: So ist es. Genau.
Das kennst du ja auch Güni.
>> GÜNTER: Ja, ja, ja.
>> MURAT: Genau, genau.
Die Waschmaschinen reden mehr miteinander
als die Pärchen.
Geiles Ding!
Wirklich! Tolles Ding!
Und eigentlich jetzt auch, wie das Ding wirklich funktioniert,
das kann euch mal Sally
in diesem jetzigen Video mal erklären.
Die kann es nämlich besser als wir erklären.
Weil irgendwie, immer wenn wir es erklären,
kommt irgendwie Mist raus.
Verstehst du, was ich meine?
>> GÜNTER: Schenkst du mir eine?
>> MURAT: Nein, ich schenke dir keine.
>> GÜNTER: Warum nicht?
>> MURAT: Warum?
Du hast doch eine Waschmaschine daheim.
Sag mal.
Du hast doch schon eine...
>> GÜNTER: Aber keine Inox.
>> MURAT: Ach, nee? Keine Inox?
>> GÜNTER: Nein.
>> MURAT: Sag mal, du hast gerade vor drei Minuten
erfahren, dass das Ding Inox heißt.
>> GÜNTER: Ja. Das habe ich mir gleich gemerkt.
>> MURAT: Ach so.
Der ist schon bescheuert!
Auf jeden Fall, schaut euch das Video an!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Jetzt darf ich euch ein Paar vorstellen,
das so richtig gut zusammenpasst,
die Bosch-Waschmaschine
und der Bosch-Trockner im Inox-Design.
Die beiden sind aber nicht nur optisch ein Paar,
sie verstehen sich auch hervorragend.
Beide können über Home Connect verbunden werden.
>> MURAT: Auf jeden Fall,
hier werden natürlich komplett
– wie soll ich es sagen? –
die Lichter eingestellt.
Hier werden Wände aufgestellt
wegen dem Schall und allem Drum und Dran.
Und das Tolle ist,
es wird viel, viel digitalisiert.
Macht man heutzutage übrigens auch...
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel mal so einen Autowerbespot seht
– also früher hat man da 20 Autos genommen,
die gleiche Modellreihe
und nur in verschiedenen Farben.
Und dann ist man die Terpentinen so entlanggefahren.
Heißt das Terpentinen?
>> GÜNTER: Serpentinen.
>> MURAT: Ah, Serpentinen. Ja.
Terpentin!
Oh, Terpentin!
>> GÜNTER: Ja, stell dir mal vor,
von dir gäbe es 20 Stück!
O Gott!
>> MURAT: Also Serpentinen. Genau.
Nicht Terpentin.
Das ist was...
So.
Auf jeden Fall...
Du darfst mich nicht rausbringen!
>> GÜNTER: Warst du nicht in der Schule?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Und zwar das Coole ist:
Man hat ja früher, wie gesagt,
bei so Fernsehwerbespots für Autos
und man wollte verschiedene Farben zeigen,
dann hat man wirklich 20 Fahrzeuge
in die Region gefahren, um diesen Werbespot zu drehen.
Und heutzutage wird alles so digitalisiert.
Das heißt, man nimmt nur ein Auto, färbt das ein
und es fällt keinem mehr auf,
dass es eigentlich gar nicht echt ist.
Genau.
Ja.
Das ist ja auch wie bei dir.
>> GÜNTER: Dann können wir dich einfärben.
>> MURAT: Ja? Ach so.
So.
>> GÜNTER: Grün.
>> MURAT: Ja, genau.
>> GÜNTER: Rosa.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> GÜNTER: Rosé.
>> MURAT: Auf jeden Fall, es fällt keinem auf.
Ist uns
– wie beim Güni,
da ist auch niemandem aufgefallen,
dass er eigentlich ganz, ganz beschränkt...
>> GÜNTER: 1,50 m Abstand.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Also eine Körperlänge, gell?
Nicht von dir.
>> GÜNTER: Von dir.
>> MURAT: Das ist jetzt aber...
>> GÜNTER: Ja, ja.
Gut, bei dir sind es anderthalb Körperlängen.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Auf jeden Fall, wie gesagt, das ganze Haus beschlagnahmt.
Du kannst kaum noch Zähne putzen gehen,
ohne dass dich jemand erwischt.
Ja, eine coole Geschichte, aber auch eine Erfahrung für uns.
Es ist aber schon heftig, muss ich sagen,
wenn man zehn Tage so einen Drehtag hat.
Und es ist wirklich von morgens bis abends.
Es wird wirklich von morgens um sieben
bis abends um 21 Uhr gedreht.
Das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn!
Dann hat meine Frau eh so viel Stress
und aus diesem Stress heraus
backt sie noch für alle noch Buchteln
oder macht noch Eis
oder macht irgendwelche Getränke
für das ganze Team.
Schon der Wahnsinn!
>> GÜNTER: Was machst du für mich?
>> MURAT: Was mache ich für dich?
Sei froh, dass ich dir nichts mache.
Ja.
Also sei froh, dass ich dir nichts mache.
>> GÜNTER: Komm, probier doch mal.
>> MURAT: Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein!
Nein, das machen wir nicht.
Auf jeden Fall richtig cool,
coole Videos
und tolle Geräte, muss man ehrlich sagen, oder?
>> GÜNTER: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ich finde es mal schön,
dass Made in Germany so extrem innovativ ist.
Oftmals wird es gar nicht erzählt.
Aber es ist Wahnsinn!
>> GÜNTER: Schenkst du mir jetzt so eine Serie?
>> MURAT: Nein, ich schenke dir keine Serie.
Du kriegst gleich von mir eine Serie,
aber eine ganz andere Serie.
So.
Genau.
>> GÜNTER: Eine andere Serie?
>> MURAT: Ja, eine andere Serie.
Jetzt geht es weiter.
>> GÜNTER: Weißt du, wie lange das dauert,
bis so eine Spanplatte
aus dem Schädel rausgeeitert ist?
>> MURAT: Ja.
Aua! Aua!
Ist der bescheuert!
Hey, ich muss es jeden Tag mit dem mitmachen.
Weißt du, das Problem war ja früher wirklich
– der beleidigt mich ja schon seit 13 Jahren.
Oder seit 14 Jahren beleidigt der mich.
Und irgendwann hat er sich gedacht,
er macht das beruflich.
Und seitdem arbeitet er bei uns.
So.
Jetzt reicht es mir langsam!
Ich erzähle meiner Frau mal,
wie böse du eigentlich immer zu mir bist.
>> GÜNTER: Mach ruhig.
>> MURAT: Sally! Sally!
[Musik]
Ich will einfach...
>> GÜNTER: Was denn?
>> MURAT: Ich will eigentlich gar nicht mehr mit dir arbeiten.
Ich sage meiner Frau,
dass ich in eine andere Abteilung möchte.
Ich möchte mit dir nicht mehr arbeiten,
weil irgendwie...
>> GÜNTER: Kann ich Homeoffice machen?
>> MURAT: Ja! Ja, mach du Homeoffice!
>> GÜNTER: Josh, ich mache Homeoffice!
[Musik]
>> MURAT: So. Jetzt bin ich allein in der Küche.
Und ihr kennt ja oftmals das Problem auf Cerankochfeldern,
Kratzer mit Töpfen oder irgendwie.
Jedes Ceranfeld ist irgendwann mal zerkratzt.
Dagegen könnt ihr nichts machen.
Aber jetzt gibt es was ganz, ganz Cooles!
Und das hat auch mit diesem Messer zu tun.
Das ist ein Masuta,
ein japanisches Damastmesser aus VG10 Goldstahl.
Und dieses Messer ist richtig scharf!
Und was die neuen Kochfelder,
die neuen Generationen so draufhaben,
das ist wirklich der Wahnsinn!
Aber am besten zeigt euch mal das die Sally.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Der erste Kratzer im Auto,
diesen Moment kennt, glaube ich, jeder.
Und der ist so ärgerlich!
Bei Kochfeldern entstehen die meisten Kratzer
durch Sand, Staub und aggressive Schwämme.
GlassProtect ist 95% kratzresistenter
gegen Sand und Staub
und 70% gegen aggressive Schwämme.
Also ich muss schon sagen,
vor der allerersten Aufnahme war ich krass aufgeregt,
weil ich einfach diese Masse an Texten vor mir hatte.
Und wir haben die Texte so gemacht
– die waren schon...
Wir hatten sie schon grob vorgeschrieben.
Florence hat mir auch jeden Tag immer was zugeschickt.
Und aber immer morgens noch mal
sind wir noch mal alles durchgegangen,
was wir an dem Tag drehen wollen.
Wir haben noch mal Änderungen gemacht:
Wo könnte man etwas einfacher oder kürzer erklären?
Weil gerade diese Videos,
das sind ja schon Erklärvideos geworden.
Also wirklich so in zwei, drei Minuten kurz:
Was ist das Wichtigste über dieses Gerät?
Und das musste ich dann eben immer aufsplitten
und habe am Tag vielleicht auch mal
über zehn Gerät gleichzeitig gesprochen
oder direkt nacheinander in der gleichen Situation.
Und das war für mich natürlich auch schwierig,
weil ich da nicht in meiner Umgangssprache
so sprechen konnte,
sondern ich musste mir praktisch den Text merken.
Oder teilweise durfte ich ihn auch ablesen.
Aber das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen schwierig,
weil ich jetzt nicht der Typ bin, der Texte abliest,
sondern eher so der Typ bin,
der so aus dem Stegreif raus spricht
und sich Sachen kurz merkt und dann eben spricht.
Und deswegen ist es vielleicht so,
dass ich in den Videos ein bisschen anders da
und kompakter und kürzer spreche.
Aber ich habe halt immer versucht,
alles so direkt auf den Punkt zu bringen.
Und dann muss man überlegen:
Die eine Situation ist Montag um 8 Uhr
drüben im Wohnzimmer entstanden.
Die nächste Situation im gleichen Video
ist Freitagnachmittag hier in der Küche entstanden.
Die wieder andere Situation
war Mittwochvormittag dort drüben.
Also es war halt echt immer
alles querbeet und durcheinander.
Aber ich muss sagen,
das Team hat es mir auch ein bisschen leicht dann gemacht.
So die ersten paar Stunden waren echt krass!
Da war ich echt aufgeregt, weil ich einfach auch nicht wusste
so vom Feedback her.
Also es hat auch immer keiner was gesagt:
War es jetzt gut oder nicht so gut?
Und irgendwann waren wir echt megaeingespielt,
auch gerade mit dem Roman, mit dem Kameramann.
Der wusste dann immer genau, was er sagen muss
oder eben so ein kurzes Feedback,
gut oder nicht so.
Und dann wusste ich auch schon,
okay, das passt oder das mache ich noch mal neu.
Und da, muss ich sagen, waren es halt
echt krasse sechs intensive Tage
von morgens bis abends.
Und ich habe auch echt schlecht geschlafen teilweise,
weil ich so dachte:
"Okay, morgen geht es jetzt um die Geschirrspülmaschine."
Und ich habe dann schon nachts geträumt
von den ganzen Geräten.
Aber ich hatte wirklich so eine Woche lang den Kopf nur hier.
Und es war schon sehr gut.
Und ich denke, dass die Videos am Ende
auch so geworden sind, dass ihr euch
die Videos einfach anschauen könnt, wenn ihr sagt:
"Okay, ich interessiere mich jetzt
für eine neue Geschirrspülmaschine."
Und dann habt ihr das Video.
Die könnt ihr übrigens auf dem Bosch-YouTube-Kanal
alle einzeln anschauen.
Die werden auch alle noch übersetzt in ganz viele Sprachen.
Es ist auch eine krasse Technik, die da dahintersteckt
und die ich selber
jetzt im Englischen schon gesehen habe,
in anderen Sprachen noch nicht.
Und ihr könnt sie auch bei uns auf dem Blog,
also auf sallys-blog.de, auch alle einzeln anklicken.
Und da wäre es auch echt cool,
wenn ihr mir einfach euer Feedback schreibt
und so gerade mit dem Hintergrund
mit dem Backstage-Video.
Also es war schon eine krasse Zeit.
Und ich muss auch sagen,
ich habe Murat die ganze Zeit über so kaum gesehen.
Und ich habe auch immer geguckt,
dass wir am Set immer ganz viel Spaß haben.
Und wir hatten auch ein schönes Catering, muss ich sagen,
weil eben nicht so viel Zeit war
zum Selberkochen und Backen,
wobei ich während den Drehs oder auch nach den Drehs,
wenn hier eingeleuchtet wurde
– und es hat schon teilweise mal so drei Stunden gedauert,
bis mal so das Set-up richtig eingeleuchtet war.
Und dann habe ich mich hingestellt und Buchteln gebacken
oder Rahmkuchen oder Schokokuchen.
Und dann gab es das so am gleichen Tag
oder am nächsten Tag für das Team.
Ja, da ist mir auch immer wichtig,
dass sich jeder bei mir zu Hause wohlfühlt
und dass das Team an sich eben gut zusammenpasst.
Und das hat dann schon gepasst.
Also da muss ich sagen, es war echt eine richtig coole Zeit.
Ja, und nachdem dann die sechs Tage Dreh hier
vorbei waren, war für mich natürlich
jetzt erst mal so der Dreh vorbei.
Und für das Team von Punchin, also für die Produktionsfirma,
hat dann eigentlich die eigentliche Arbeit
noch mal richtig angefangen.
Denn danach haben sie noch mal,
ich glaube, sechs oder sieben Wochen lang
die ganzen Videos geschnitten
und auch 3D-Animationen eingebaut.
Also das ist schon echt aufwendig gewesen.
Und ich finde, das sieht man auch in den Videos.
Es sind echt schöne Videos geworden
und
auch sehr informativ, muss ich sagen.
Und ich persönlich finde,
es war für dieses Jahr
– also für dieses Pandemiejahr, nenne ich es jetzt mal,
war es echt eine tolle Alternative,
vor allem, weil ich eben doch
zum einen mit dem Bosch-Team
ganz intensiv arbeiten konnte
und wir uns echt super ausgetauscht haben,
ich euch die Neuheiten jetzt eben vorstellen konnte.
Aber ich muss sagen,
ich hoffe natürlich für das nächste Jahr,
dass die Messe oder überhaupt alle Messen
wieder stattfinden könnten.
Vielleicht unter anderen Bedingungen.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich kann das selber jetzt nicht vorhersagen.
Ich wünsche mir natürlich,
dass ich nächstes Jahr wieder auf der Messe stehe
und für euch kochen und backen kann.
Was ich aber tatsächlich dieses Jahr gut fand,
war zum einen, dass
auch Bosch als Firma, muss ich echt sagen,
– also Hut ab –
dass so ein großer Konzern, kann man ja schon sagen,
so spontan war und
so schnell auch darauf reagiert hat,
dass wirklich die Messe trotzdem stattfinden konnte.
Und ich finde, das haben wahrscheinlich nicht alle gemacht
und da ist Bosch echt ein innovatives Team
und sagt auch: "Okay, komm, wir haben jetzt den Mut.
Wir machen das jetzt einfach. Wir probieren es einfach",
und da einfach nicht stehen bleiben
und sagen: "Okay, uns sind jetzt die Hände gebunden.
Wir machen einfach nichts draus."
Und das, muss ich sagen, finde ich ganz gut.
Ich konnte mich vor allem auf alle technischen Neuerungen
vorbereiten und mich auch wirklich darauf konzentrieren,
sodass diese Einzelvideos entstehen.
Da, muss ich nämlich sagen, habe ich auf den Messen
eher weniger Zeit oder weniger die Gelegenheit,
weil ich einfach
– wenn ich auf der Messe rumlaufe,
werde ich natürlich oft auch angesprochen
oder ich unterhalte mich selber mit anderen.
Und dann ist natürlich die Konzentration nicht so da,
wie wenn du gezielt dann ein Video für ein Produkt machst.
Und das fand ich jetzt ganz gut.
Ich glaube, ich für mich fände es ganz schön,
für das nächste Jahr
so eine Kombination aus beidem zu machen,
also schön die Videoproduktion
für die einzelnen Geräte zu machen,
aber dann eben auch auf die Messe zu gehen.
Und ihr könnt mir ja mal euer Feedback geben,
wie ihr das jetzt so fandet,
wie wir die IFA dieses Jahr gelöst haben.
Und ja, schreibt mir gerne euer Feedback dazu.
Ich hoffe, euch hat dieses Video gefallen.
Ich denke, man hätte einfach noch so viel mehr
backstage zeigen können.
Ich habe auch zum Josh gesagt:
"Josh, komm einfach ab und zu rüber.
Wir machen Backstage-Aufnahmen."
Aber ich war einfach nonstop beim Dreh
und hatte natürlich den Kopf dann auch gar nicht mehr frei.
Und oft waren Josh und Sarah
und auch die anderen vom Team
einfach nur da, um mir mal einen Kaffee zu bringen,
einfach Zeit mit mir zu verbringen,
kurz Musik hören,
kurz ausrasten und Karaoke singen
und einfach so kurz wieder,
ja, irgendwie die Welt normal werden lassen.
Oder, Josh? Es war schon so.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Es war schon so teilweise so:
"Komm, Sally! Zieh es noch durch!
Du schaffst es!"
Weil man hätte natürlich den ganzen Dreh
auch auf zwei Wochen aufteilen können,
dass es eben nicht so ganz zeitintensiv war.
Aber wir haben gesagt:
"Komm, eine Woche. Wir schaffen es."
Und wir haben es geschafft.
Und ich muss sagen, dafür haben wir es
echt ganz cool gemacht.
Also noch mal ein ganz, ganz großes Dankeschön auch
an das komplette Punchin-Team!
Ihr habt das echt super gemacht!
Und ich muss sagen,
ich bin ja echt so ein Mensch, ich kann...
Also ich bin schon ein Mensch,
ich kann, würde ich sagen, mit jedem.
Also mit mir kann, glaube ich, jeder arbeiten.
Aber bei mir muss halt echt
immer die Sympathie überspringen.
Also ich kann auch keinem in die Kamera lachen,
den ich irgendwie nicht mag.
Und dann
– also ich kann mich halt nicht verstellen.
Das ist halt echt so.
Und wenn ich mich im Team wohlfühle,
dann fällt mir der Dreh auch leicht.
Und wenn ich die Person dahinter
– wenn die so kalt zu mir sind,
dann kann ich das halt auch nicht.
Und da, muss ich sagen,
hat es echt super gepasst.
Und deswegen habe ich mich auch megawohl gefühlt.
Und ich hoffe, dass sich auch jeder bei uns wohlgefühlt hat.
Ja.
Also so viel dazu.
Und ich habe dann immer
so ganz, ganz schlimme Abschiedsschmerzen.
Das ist echt bei mir...
Ich bin, glaube ich
– immer zu schnell nehme ich so Menschen
voll in mein Herz auf.
Und dann habe ich am Ende immer so:
"O Gott! Jetzt gehen alle!"
Und dann war ich so
alleine wieder
mit meinen Kindern und mit dem Murat.
Aber es war auch natürlich dann wieder sehr schön.
Ja. Jedenfalls wollte ich nur sagen,
dass ich alle sehr mochte.
Das war so die Aussage, die ich treffen wollte.
Okay. Der Josh guckt schon so.
Okay.
Also ich hoffe, ihr hattet Spaß bei diesem Backstage-Video.
Oh, was ich noch sagen muss
– apropos Sympathie.
Oben, als wir im Hauswirtschaftsraum gedreht haben,
das war ja praktisch
– also das sind schon so unsere privatesten Räume,
Schlafzimmer, Kinderzimmer,
Ankleide- und – keine Ahnung – Waschraum.
Und da haben wir wirklich auf so drei Quadratmetern
– in diesem Miniwaschraum haben wir einfach gefilmt.
Und es war so krass warm
durch die ganzen Lichter, die Waschmaschine und alles.
Und, um das Ganze dann immer aufzulockern,
war ich dann immer bei Ela in ihrer Verkleidungskiste.
Und dann haben wir uns alle verkleidet,
so als Engel und als Marienkäfer.
Und ja, also wir hatten schon ziemlich viel Spaß beim Dreh.
Ja.
Es war eine lustige Zeit.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
Und, wie gesagt, die Videos könnt ihr euch
auf dem Bosch-YouTube-Kanal anschauen.
Es wäre auch megacool, wenn ihr sie euch anschaut, denn
es steckt einfach so viel Arbeit dahinter.
Und ich finde, wenn ihr sie euch mal anguckt
und vielleicht was schreibt dazu,
wäre das schon ganz schön.
Denn, ich muss auch sagen, das Thema
– vielleicht echt das noch als Nachtrag.
Das Thema von Bosch dieses Jahr
war eben auch das Thema Nachhaltigkeit und Gesundheit.
Und das muss ich schon sagen.
Die haben zum Beispiel
ihre kompletten Geschirrspüler alle geändert,
also wirklich die alten Produktionen aufgehört zu produzieren
und wirklich alles ganz neu
mit Filtern, die man eben nicht mehr tauschen muss,
wirklich ganz nachhaltig,
dass wenig Müll entsteht und so weiter.
Auch, was das Thema Küchendunstabzugshaube
oder Backöfen und so weiter,
Kühlschränke angeht,
mehr Platz für mehr Frisches, für mehr Obst und Gemüse.
Also das Thema Nachhaltigkeit und Gesundheit
ist Bosch wirklich superwichtig.
Und da finde ich die technischen Innovationen echt mega!
Also schaut es euch gerne an
und hinterlasst uns euer Feedback.
Tschüss!
Lika a Bosch!
[Musik]